but really the question is did you ever
worry because it seems like someone
you're not someone that would i would
worry
that maybe bipolar manic depressive
they're both the same thing utterly
right i mean
um oh if you opened up the diagnostic
you know there's the that manual this
big i can never
remember that it's it's the pd something
i can't remember what it's a
diagnostic manual for all mental illness
if you open it up
and i'm sure this is true for a lot of
people but if you look you know i am
sure that i satisfy
a great number of the criteria that
would be listed on it so
the good you know we talk about my wife
the to have a partner
in managing
my mental life is uh
a gift from god really and then you know
yeah it's just very aware of
me and my life and my history and
just keeps keeps an eye keeps an eye
and then the other thing i was saying
was that we have kids and it is a
hereditary
uh situation you know the thing about
the conical thing just going back for a
second about doctors
here they are not very iconic
very conical they're going to want to
say something about that diagnosis
their jobs doctors jobs are
uh constantly under threat of like
the liability that they live under
everything they say
could ruin their career their practice
their financial life
their kids fortune so doctors
generally will lean on a more
severe interpretation of what uh you
know
uh uh you know um just they they give
you a harder diagnosis than
cover the bases yeah but i mean you're
like well it's a permanent thing well it
wasn't permanent
but you know what i can never say to the
guy after five years you never said that
it was still gonna be with me after you
misrepresented right you said something
you said it would go away how many girls
do you know who are like i was told i
could never have children
yeah true right right well people like
you you'll never walk again
right when they walk right if anything
it gives you uh
what's the word ambition or or no not
hope i mean
that would be a hopeless thing to hear i
mean you never
walk again i think you meant the idea
that they're not true always can give
you hope but no yes no they give you
determination determination yeah
determination i mean that's really where
people decide who they are
like how are you going to receive such a
harsh
uh diagnosis but i think with mental
illness
you know my mom's mental illness her
thing was
use her diagnosis as a
i think we talked about this last time
but um
as an identity like
who are you are you the person who
behaved badly
on a few sets and in relationships and
had a reputation
for being volatile or are you a person
who is
a champion for something that you've
overcome
so she chose she chose that one so wow
we all pick what we want our
narrative to be what we want our
relationship to the public to be
and um so i've always engaged the mental
health
bipolar discussion from the point of
view of someone who grew up from a
family member
as a family member survivor in a way
right